Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui dans ScienceClic, le modèle standard
Le modèle standard regroupe toutes les
particules élémentaires
qui composent l'univers, en une seule théorie.
Les particules
élémentaires sont les éléments
fondamentaux à la base de l' univers
tout entier.
Ce sont les particules plus petites,
qu'on ne peut pas diviser.
Le modèle standard regroupe ces
particules élémentaires en plusieurs groupes
Tout d'abord l'univers est composé de
matière.
La matière est à la base des êtres
vivants, des planètes, des étoiles et de
tout ce qui possède une masse.
Les particules élémentaires qui
composent la matière,
sont des fermions.
Il existe deux grandes
catégories de fermions :
Les quarks, et les leptons.
Les quarks et les leptons
qui composent la matière existent
sous différentes formes, qui sont classés en trois générations.
Pour chaque génération, sont associés un couple de quarks et un couple de leptons.
La première génération comporte les
particules élémentaires les plus
communes, que l'on peut observer partout.
Cette première génération est
composé des quarks up et down
et des leptons électron et neutrino
électronique.
En s'associant par groupes de trois,
les quarks up et down
forment les protons et les neutrons,
qui sont les constituants essentiels du
noyau des atomes.
Les électrons sont également présents dans les atomes,
orbitant autour des protons et des neutrons,
et leur charge négative
permet de compenser la charge positive
des protons, afin que la matière reste
neutre.
Avec une charge nulle.
En circulant dans des fils de connexion,
les électrons sont également à la base de l'électricité.
Enfin, les neutrinos électroniques sont
les particules de matière les plus
nombreuses dans l'univers. En effet plus
de mille milliards de neutrinos
traversent notre corps chaque seconde.
Ils ont pour particularité de ne pas interagir avec la matière,
ce qui les rend très difficile à détecter.
La deuxième génération de la matière
est composé des quarks charm et strange
et des leptons muon et neutrino muonique.
Ces quatre particules ont une masse plus importante que celles de la première génération.
Enfin, la troisième génération est
composée des quarks top et bottom
et des leptons tau, et neutrino tauique.
Ces quatre particules sont les plus massives
par rapport aux deux premières générations.
Les particules de la deuxième et de la troisième génération sont très rares dans l'univers,
qui est presque entièrement constitué
de particules de la première génération.
Toutes les particules de matière
existent en deux versions.
En effet, il existe une autre forme de
matière, qu'on appelle l'antimatière,
qui associe à chaque particule son antiparticule.
Les antiparticules ont toutes les mêmes caractéristiques que les particules normales,
sauf leur charge, qui est opposée.
Ensuite, il existe des particules qui ne sont pas des constituants de la matière,
qu'on appelle des bosons.
Un boson est une particule qui va agir comme pour un messager,
pour permettre l’interaction à distance entre deux particules de matière.
Quatre de ces bosons sont appelés bosons de jauge.
Ces bosons de jauge représentent chacun une force de l'univers.
Le photon est le boson de jauge associé
à l'interaction électromagnétique.
Il se déplace à la vitesse de la
lumière,
et il est à la base du magnétisme, ou
encore de la lumière elle même.
Le gluon est le boson de jauge associé à l’interaction forte.
Cette force agit à un niveau microscopique, et est très puissante.
C'est elle qui maintient entre eux les quarks,
qui forment les protons et les neutrons.
Enfin, les bosons Z0, W+ et W-,
sont les bosons de jauge associés à
l'interaction faible. Cette force
est à la base de phénomènes comme la
radioactivité des particules, ou la
fusion nucléaire qui a lieu
au sein des étoiles comme le Soleil.
Il existe dans le modèle standard un
dernier boson, le boson de Higgs.
Le boson de Higgs ne représente pas
une force, mais un champ.
Le champ de Higgs.
Ce champ de Higgs attribue une masse aux particules qui le traversent.
Plus les particules interagissent avec le
champ,
plus elle ont une masse importante.
Il existe donc dans l'univers une grande
diversité de particules élémentaires,
que le modèle standard regroupe en une
seule théorie,
mais cette théorie n'explique pas tout.
Par exemple, le modèle standard n'inclut
pas encore la force de gravitation,
qui est essentielle à l'univers. Pour cela les
physiciens ont suggéré l'existence
d'un boson, qui transmettrait l'interaction
gravitationnelle,
le graviton. Mais son existence n'est
pour l'instant qu'une hypothèse.